I can't [ __ ] get your [ __ ] boy
psychobabble we're back and I'm going to
try to pummel these two episodes out
baby episode 4 thicker than semen let's
do this when she really is threatened
from with it xavier managers unlikely
alliances for the safety of his loved
ones now this means not for the safety
of others that he doesn't consider stuff
you know you got to be quicker this gave
you by sharper wit okay what I don't
taking like ten years of charge I got I
get a lot of blueberries here like that
I thought John was that falsely vulgar
hurt left you're a piece of work you
know that okie Garcias you is just my
goddamn guts out huh Joe was in on it we
did it on her orders oh I'm sorry
though he's too later sorry you
backstabbing [ __ ]
yeah he's faster than [ __ ] I'll tell
everyone a Richmond about this no way
maybe he'll be useful thank you thanks
David I see so much darker than me I
needed that the other thing I like
all right let's David stop which is good
but I'm like happy like this and the
people mouth doctor right hold it there
folks and I consider explaining
yourselves I asked you to get Kate and
Gabe's safe not tuck your tail and run
this is not over Joan I have friends
here allies welcome pick up what
happened laughs is that it yeah okay
I'll rap blossom it's a good band here's
last night okay oh um I got a claim
where the games here is adaptive choices
you make okay just say now
Conrad well to Kate Davis just a piece
of shap one I'm out of practice that's
all seem here I haven't held a bat since
the league booted me well you got all
afternoon to get back in the groove oh
yeah
just holding this thing makes me feel
better just she said all right Annie
swing swing Lonnie you doing okay uh
I've been wrestling with something hey
man you're Xavier Garcia right the
ballplayer
can I get your autograph [ __ ] off can be
fall that would be so awesome
sure thinking oh thank you
who do I make this out to oh no no no
names band players signatures are worth
way more on resale than personalized
crap just your name is fine don't date
it or anything okay hope you like it oh
yeah I might get 10 bucks for this you
made that fantasy big stars let's get
back to baseball I mean it's not I hear
holy cow
you just had to rub it in didn't you
just talking like that make you feel
better
yes yeah you should try it what a
worthless piece of [ __ ] strike two
man knock that [ __ ] off I'm serious you
just talk talk talk it's annoying
I'm not stopping is way too much fun I'm
not kidding
Garcia is going ballistic I still can't
believe you actually wanted to come here
if I were in your situation
avoid batting cages forever well thanks
for bringing me anyway
I needed the distraction
Oh
Garcia's on fire it's Robert amigos
boosted plenty Robin and next time we go
to the shooting range
I don't really shoot but I you and I'm
good at oh what a stupid [ __ ] sting I
pay my attention bass hold blame man on
me gotta pay attention now the batting
cage is serious business you're about
the last person who should be telling
people about serious business hobby I
remember I showed you how to play this
game well let this superstar return the
favor
watch this crusher oh my god the crowd
is going why it you don't have to rub it
in my face I'm done I'll rub it in this
guy's face
David hey free knock off the tantrum bro
off you just can't resist making your
little digs Ken no ha be the star
thinking he's better than me yes that's
gonna change what's going on David I
don't understand you don't understand
because you only think about yourself
and I'm sick of it
it's been that way for years I'm just
sick of your attitude David you love to
mock me but you have no idea what I deal
with my job sucks
Kate and I fight like cats and dogs I
belong back in the army
I had a purpose there I had respect
oh you know what yeah do what you need
to do the army could be good for you I
was expecting more of an argument now I
bet between me and Kate and going
downhill for a while if I left seemed
like that would be best for everyone
yep I can't keep pretending this is the
life I want
not anymore I'm not gonna stand in your
way
well alright then I'm not gonna lie if I
go it's gonna be hard on everyone
all right la may need help from time to
time you can help right you won't leave
her hanging
I need to know that I'll be there for
them since you won't you want to go you
should go about time you grew up pest
kiss kiss kiss um
come on come on I want to get out of
here now is he going to kiss some worms
it's just wasting time here oh yeah sour
blue air Jesus
get in there you two John's gonna figure
out what to do with you she's making a
huge mistake no you made a mistake when
you tried to attack her hey everybody
just take a breath all right I was just
trying to tell them that's your mistake
right there
you can't fight everybody understand
that Joan's not looking for revenge she
just wants Porter cooperation is the
name of the game there's still away
through this I'll I'll see what I can do
what you're going to choose that which
overbeat out better start leaning on
your brother hobby he needs to get with
a program
click I'm over that theater go I want to
make it out of here just relax and trust
in the process but that Shep I don't
suck dicks I get my dick sucked after I
brought you in after I saved your asses
this is how you treat me
betrayal lies David I'm not your enemy
we have to figure out what to do about
John Jones betrayal wasn't as bad as
yours little brother do you see what
Jones doing the power drowned
Puran sister she could have found a way
to protect all of you but now now you're
all on your own
you gotta still have some friends here
right she managed to flip Clint and
lingard to her side somehow without them
it's hopeless it's everyone out for
themselves these days we wouldn't be in
this situation if you paid attention to
what Joan was up I did my best
I have always done my back oh you have
it I can't say I never tried I have
always given a hundred percent oh yeah
tell that to Kate
you left her behind once already maybe
it's time you try a different way oh my
god Gundy North End any if we get out of
here you're on your own
I'm through with you punch up
difficult brothers fighting like boys
you [ __ ] I [ __ ] trusted you
careful don't give him a concussion I
came here to talk not fight you're not
gonna be a problem
are you I just want a calm discussion
between us
you've got the guns you set the terms
I'm glad you're willing to work with me
mm-hmm
it's sad how we ended up here but
Clinton lingard agree
you've become a problem tomorrow morning
I'm going to call for a gathering in the
square the people deserve to hear a full
explanation of your arrest and then then
you'll be replaced as head of security
no one's above the law David not even
you what the [ __ ] I thought you loved
Joe you're the one breaking them this
place could have been something
something good and you ruined it this
place needs me to keep it safe you set
me up everyone's gonna see through your
life I did what I had to do to keep the
people of Richmond safe they're going to
see that and they'll also see that the
biggest threat to them right now is you
[ __ ]
I understand you're angry with me but
let's talk about it in private bring him
with us oh so do I like escape I hear
the way the [ __ ] about may I get out of
here
okay go through those vents doc now
thank ya papi sure it's not the way okay
happen ah yeah space let me talk about
it perfectly good space could squeeze
through there okay what else is here
stat on I'm not gonna get up there from
this bench you [ __ ] [ __ ]
move this number this else is here okay
what the [ __ ] am i doing just causing
destruction that doesn't look very
sturdy no lamp is the focus how do I use
this take a shower well it's about the
kind of day I'm having okay
why they like leave all this [ __ ] here
[ __ ] okay so here's a new plan javi okay
I wasn't sure how I was going to find
you then I heard the glass breaking hey
no you escaped the guards barely we got
to get you out of here take this help me
pry these bars off give it a push from
your side okay Joe thanks key now give
me a hand that Kate was like [ __ ]
darling all right let's get in the car
get the [ __ ] out of here
what's all that noise you're not what
I'd ask batch
you've got this place surrounded come on
this way
where are you taking me
Eleanor found a place Gabe's ear with
the others we've been hiding out there
first long as we can anyway how safe is
it Steve enough for now what we should
hit the road as soon as we can okay
let's do that we should probably keep
moving where are the patrols oh they're
around I had some close calls on my way
to find you almost got caught but I got
lucky you must be feeling better if
you're sneaking around like this I'm not
really oh okay I'll get my read on your
faith all clear come on
I thought you're still bleeding
internally I saw them kick David from
the quarantine building yeah how's he
doing
it's a [ __ ] Lobster I can't be his
life anymore but he doesn't deserve to
be locked away he was angry but I think
he understands I hope you're right I
still feel terrible about what's
happening to him I know it's kind of a
dick Oh get down [ __ ] I think it's
clear let's move
okay be the way
[ __ ] he says Eleanor and gave already
Barry that's [ __ ] up looking for you
it's only a matter of time before they
find the room empty they can keep
looking because we're gonna be ha to
Richmond soon come on Beth just kiss my
batch
that's on the north place
that's a lot of activity all of a sudden
I don't like that
we got a dish two kids so we got no
choice we got dish kids come on let's
get inside
[Applause]
episode 4 the walk and the walking say
men the walking Dave the walking cat
Ilan
ship are on the front I miss that
oh no don't tell me that they're
building lock cabins
oh my god CMM seamen
I got old one
how many gray hair like why why do they
not have like bucket okay what's going
on
the [ __ ] is that's like a hang near is
going what the [ __ ] is that are they
building
Wow it would take a public [ __ ] noose
like Lynch please
thicker fancy man episode war
okay okay like that thank you like that
episode for ya I'm sorry I don't know if
I feel like that wait hey buddy
fine Gabey like that FINA hassled on
acting like a little [ __ ] see how far
that gets you
who you are I can say whatever I want
that's right you can I just can't do
this now oh hey hey trip look who's here
hey guys hey where have you been
Joan threw me and David in jail if you
can believe it great so you gave these
people more reason to hate it what is
going on here in Richmond you know more
about this place than the rest of us
it's dangerous for us here we've got to
go we got to get the [ __ ] out of here
we're safer here safer than anyone else
tell that to my brother he's still in
their custody
I want to go save my dad right now he
needs our help
yeah no way it's just too dangerous
we're leaving batches esting for
families to get out of here
of course you would say that you already
tried running away once listen here you
lost shell out the window go look for
yourself
when I was like don't brush down
I can't I like to build us a Spence
build the suspense we did I didn't do it
if she actually did it
[ __ ] javi even if you did get your
brother free you're not going to be able
to go anywhere I never said anything
about getting my brother fresh as much
as I don't want to be here
you sure are glad we didn't stumble into
that on our own [ __ ] yeah
can you imagine would have been worth
risking it to get away from all this be
able to start fresh you and me babe
stupid but brave it seems like we're in
danger with in this place and without I
for one would feel a whole lot safer
with a few more guns to protect
ourselves
alright if you stay here or just move to
make right now that's crazy
we gotta be safe we'll need to make sure
we can defend ourselves no matter what
we do next
okay defend that's all you're doing I
don't want to risk us losing anybody
else but you don't seem to mind that I
know where there's gun my dad showed me
there are a lot I can take us okay
sounds like a plan Gabe you little [ __ ]
I can't trust anymore as soon as we can
I can't I can't trust him
come here Kate I just be careful kiss
her kiss her
he's gonna kiss her what your little
shed look javi I don't know if you heard
us but I think I [ __ ] it up with
Eleanor we can talk on the way about
that I don't think I can leave this
apartment with things like this between
me and her it's just not right all right
I know you must have at least heard
something it happens especially these
days don't worry about it
Thanks just certain to pushed it with
her like I did wasn't fair too much
going on already I'm Ronnie come on just
give us a minute pal no one likes scary
buddy I just I don't know what to do
just follow your heart that's all any of
us have left anymore all right thanks
man okay we're gonna kiss me or what
they like LR get out of here I'll talk
it over with Eleanor and watch over
things here you've got my word I won't
let anything happen to anyone
thank you Harvey come on good luck a
little [ __ ] I hate that kid Gabe I
really do go across the water okay let's
do this
stealer be careful you'll be fine okay
this will be great we got this slow down
buddy
I've done this before hobby no you
haven't keep not really some decisions
you make them in a split second and then
have to carry them the rest of your life
you understand okay you're so dumb and
so stupid what do you mean honey if you
get cornered and you feel your life is
in danger
and show no mercy okay Gabriel I
remember that important to me than any
of these other people no that's not real
no mercy right if it comes to that game
but the takeaway from that was supposed
to be to protect yourself first and last
okay don't hurt anybody unless you have
to okay we don't want to make any noise
and attract any attention hey I can go
talk to him while you sneak inside I'll
distract him you won't do anything to me
it's a good idea Gabe I can do this yeah
don't [ __ ] it up Gabe hey oh hey I saw
something sure
alright get in I [ __ ] get in there get
in there
my name is Javier Consuelo okay okay God
let's go let's go con come on get into
this yeah I guess I have to do it for
hem where you can't just enter the place
with self
oh no the alarms off your [ __ ] wait what
am i doing trying to save David escape
you know told you it'd work I hate this
kid buddy [ __ ] was that gay story is
doing okay let's go oh come on okay you
guys have to prepare themselves before
they walk at all come on right just come
on you know we'll just lick your lips
are you gonna just sit there it's down
here oh we're doing guns right this is a
[ __ ] trap locked no time to look for
a key either we have to break and [ __ ]
I have to do this the hard way seems
like a bad idea to me
[ __ ] loud a [ __ ]
one more batch what if I just don't do
it I press that I pressed it I don't get
how take off the doorknob opens the door
okay doesn't matter how loud it is when
you get an act as a [ __ ] you have all
the guns you need oh good choice gave
it's the first control she's made all
day but he's an amateur you don't want
to go for the big boys they just use up
all the ammo right away and put this guy
right there I get out what about you
okay there we go he's a perfect choice
fire burst semi-auto good I'll take all
the image Viper ammunition okay don't
tell me I gotta pick it up for this guy
yeah you hold sideways like it does
before you and me you make a pretty good
team right now unless you one-two punch
I just don't like putting you at risk
it's not that I don't appreciate your
help buddy whatever a second stupid
[ __ ] drop it
what the hell are you doing here it's a
lady with a tip we're getting gun
getting guns what does it look like yeah
it was a [ __ ] thing to do [ __ ] off on
me like that I know why didn't you meet
me at the stronghold we had a plan
I just can't be a part of what's going
on in New Richmond the lining and this
feeling you sound just like your brother
I know he'd want me to help you no
matter what but why should I trust you
now as far as I can tell you're nothing
but trouble because what Joan is doing
is wrong I guess I can't really say no
to that hate this it looks like you
could use all the help you can get
awesome I gotta grab something else real
quick
Nene by the front I don't trust her or
her tips okay quick got the guns are
talking around
like some of this too quiet
there it goes get your gums out boy come
here what happens if I just don't run
okay breathe do nothing do nothing get
away from you
oh [ __ ] hobbies you're bleeding
are you okay yes stupid [ __ ] bear
machine can't leave you guys alone for
two minutes can't agree he's still alive
yeah uh pesto
starting to think siding with you might
have not been the best idea possibly
been getting the closets in there I've
even added some funny [ __ ] let me see
that wound it's really bleeding you're
gonna need that taken town no no it's
okay wyngarde and David or close friends
we can count on him to help you medical
facilities right nearby
now look quiet it's not just those
quacks yeah
but let's be quick second [ __ ]
so I can get I'm gonna take that knife
[Music]
can we really hit targets over a mile
away
not these some models hobby it's
probably best if lingard doesn't see
these guns he and David might be tight
but he's still part of Richmond
Leadership Council
I'll keep watch with IVA okay do you
want anything have laser sights
so [ __ ] you just cut suicide or
something or you take drugs
[ __ ] hobby what happened to you Clem
whoops I'm [ __ ] you down here wow
that looks like it must have heard I
just need to get it cleaned up he
surprised me thought you were someone
else
looking for something but it's not like
it's not like what I'm just here to talk
to lien guard about where AJ is now
anyway
I can't leave Richmond without heard out
there something tells me lingard doesn't
care what you're doing
you've been out of it since I got here
he's a lot in the charging port dumb
bastard that's gonna need more than just
cleaning javi I can stitch that for you
I can't promise it'll look great once it
heals all right go for it but if I lose
my arm that's on you ha ha you'll be
fine
I've dealt with worse how they I'm
[ __ ] computer Mikey what are they
always leave it on for that what I'm to
her she's pregnant you okay I'm fine
oh this crime started bleeding I know
it's a thing I've traveled with women
before and they all had it what is it I
mean like why is it I just don't
understand it means you're growing up
blossoming into your you know like
warming hood your body is developing
anything things changed but it'll be
okay okay I can take you back to Kate
she can help you with her hobby
worry about yourself right now we need
to find a needle and thread to stitch
you up first
oh right
slap man
kind of silly not what I'm looking for
Cody hmm not much left and looks like
painkillers are in high demand I
wouldn't steal any medicine if I were
you
it really doesn't go over well
no thanks okay research this jackpot
needle and thread all sterilized and
ready to go
here we go
perfect perfect
yes step a [ __ ] hey this is just what
you're looking for
they help you handle Kate we'll take
care of you
now take care my batch think I remember
how to do that how great okay hold still
try not to breathe okay China out it I
guess
look I know I'm probably not the best
person to talk to you about that stuff
to do she weren't that bad thanks for
you know being here basically all this
means is you could become a mom if you
want it funny I already felt like a mom
even Ava would have to admit I was a
good mom to AJ yeah great there we go
second flashbacks you're sucking [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this was an after she lost AJ Savea well
there Clem it's just me that tips
what how do you want I know how pissed
you are Clementine sitting on David
really got that message across good
believe it or not I'm actually sorry
about what happened it wasn't easy for
any of the sukkah that's ah I deserve
that
I got you my worst I'm not here to upset
you more too late
look it's not much but here
there's a bag full of tampons my god
it's another baby
Oh chilly
oh babe a it's right
David wanted you to have that AJ drew it
just after you thank you you're welcome
consider it a peace offering no [ __ ] you
[ __ ] I care about you just try to
remember that even if it feels wrong
people can still be trying to do the
right thing by you like you're trying to
put on too much makeup dangerous out
here and right now you're hurting mm-hmm
whatever you do you can't let what
happens go to you okay you need to keep
a level head my Marshman plan for after
that you're strong but that won't get
you far if you don't know what you're
doing or where you're headed I could
maybe find some others town something we
all have to fit in somewhere right
Melbourne because it didn't work out
with us doesn't mean you won't find
happiness somewhere else I could take my
baby for me staying alive has always
been about finding people I could trust
as much as they trusted me that's what
the new frontier has been a silver
lining
made me feel worth a damn kept me going
in the worst of times doing a medal or
offenders I know you will someone or
something you people stole mine you know
that you'll just have to find something
new that shut the hell up from the first
time we met right here surrounded by
absolute hell you and AJ were a light in
the darkness
hope for a better world that's who you
are
promise me you'll never lose that light
Oh God [ __ ] it's what makes you special
Clem just go away already okay okay I
should get back before anyone notices
I'm gone those good people you mentioned
before the ones you said would be out
there well there's an old airfield about
ten or so miles south of here Prescott
there are definitely good people there
I'm sure they'll take you in I'll miss
having you around to Clem [ __ ] you [ __ ]
are you leaving or what I hope the best
for you out there kid I really do like
she took my daughter like I'm not gonna
be like like okay wait nice to me I'll
be nice to you like no like she took my
daughter she's going there's things I
have to stay alive to do so what do you
think that's good
I think I'm getting better
nice work Thanks
glad I could help
you coming I still have to ask lingard
about AJ hello Clementine Xavier thought
you were running a cell with David there
any chance he got out too I hate to
think about what Gillian might do Joan
took him before I got out I'm soon sings
that poor bastard he's he's not good now
no sorry this is only one sure way to
get away from Joel nice day why do you
care David got out he deserves what's
coming to him if you think that you
don't know David I know he's the reason
I lost AJ when AJ recovered David was
the one who stepped up took personal
responsibility for that key ah yeah it's
a good thing he [ __ ] took him
I really doubt he was a positive
influence David's the reason the kids
bed off now he'd ever be where is David
didn't be as mad as you want how other
things panned out Clem can be the judge
of that she doesn't need to be as a
doctor I'm telling you he's in better
shape now than when I first saw him okay
where is it I never gave up on him sure
as hell not gonna start now I stand by
what I said if David's taken such good
care of him why did he tell me to ask
you where AJ is that's what this is
about then you you want to know where
the boy is
yeah the [ __ ] okay everyone's like quiet
cuz they're like obviously
what do you want I I just wanna die I
want you to inject this into me why
don't you do it yourself
I can't I'm [ __ ] cow when your
brother found me he he got me to care
about everything I'd given up on my life
other people even this goddamn place
without him around I don't want to care
anymore just tell me where he is and you
won't have any reason to do it
hobby I have to know okay all right I'll
do it
well where is he
jeez is that the McCarran ranch few
miles west of here
he's really alive don't do it Oh what
the [ __ ]
don't forget to stick around the handle
the after pot I don't want to become one
of those months and forget Jones looking
for you and your friend
you better hope she doesn't
I've got it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
I don't have to do do I knows no don't
do it I'm not gonna do it
oh hey uh hi
comment I'm surprised to see you here
yeah
all right back at you you all good yeah
we're all set let's roll
mmm good to see you
[Music]
hmm
hobbie your back and Clementine thanks
for the warm welcome just surprised to
see you is all guys this is Eva oh yeah
I know who she is she's got a hell of a
punch nice to meet you
good to see you Ava oh hell you okay
yeah he looks worse than it is don't
worry about it
Kate's lying down in the other room for
a bit so you got the gun huh yeah happy
the zombie I'm gonna be so good for you
anyone for you I saved this one for you
no I've already got one Oh actually it
wouldn't hurt to have another Thanks
what took you so long
we went to see dr. lingard at night I'm
kind of surprised he was sober it's
gotta be a stressful job looking after
an entire community he was definitely
not a hundred percent bear that's for
sure sounds about right
mal raeng Clementine killed him why
don't you go talk to Keith okay okay
she's [ __ ] zombie even a guy I write
in a few hours
Jones people know we're holed up here
and they're gonna come looking for us
all of us [ __ ] sake maybe it's not as
bad as we think
[ __ ] four years and there's no goin
anywhere with those things blocking our
exit you like me that has to help
somehow just cuz he like you doesn't
mean they're gonna like the rest of us
we're sitting ducks up here
we've still got time to get in front of
this before John can do anything yeah I
don't know about you but I'm not going
to sit around and wait for her to find
us I'm liking the cut of your jib
Bobby we can't just cut it chop it but
okay the hurt out there like it or not
we're [ __ ] stuck in Richmond how the
[ __ ] are we gonna put the brakes on this
thing Jonah and her people are going to
be at the square
we need to bring the fight to them we go
after Joan our problems are solved great
so how do we do that it's a good
question
Joan will probably have a full security
detail with her we move in fast guns
blazing we take her out a couple of
bullets problem solved
after we take Joan out we're gonna need
some way out of this mess I don't know
about the rest of you I'm not much of a
runner we've got a truck a big one that
we used to use for Walker defense it's a
little busted up but it's way better
than nothing
people are gonna be patrolling these
streets looking for us how far away is
this truck
I'll show you we've been expanding
pushing out further making the safe zone
even bigger can't promise you they've
cleared all the walkers yes but that's
where the trucks parked I could spit and
hit it we steal that thing nothing will
be able to stop us steal what hey Jesus
javi is it plus on your shirt you said
it wasn't that bad it isn't how the hell
did this happen yes sir oh you're
bleeding right through that bandage you
should have told me as soon as you got
in not deep it's just led a lot besides
it's already taken care of Clementine
sewed me up back at the doctors you
still didn't answer my question what
happened she got stabbed okay by one of
the guards thought you knew what you
were doing you're still alive aren't you
Eleanor can you take a look at this as
long as he keeps it clean it should be
okay would you guys stop making such a
big deal about it it happened it's over
move on already I'm just trying to make
sure he's okay Gabe what we need to be
talking about is the plan oh I have a
bunch of ideas I want to be the one to
go after dad just give me a gun and I'll
do whatever
stop talking Gabe I know what dad's
gonna be thinking let the grown-ups come
up with a plan okay Gabe cause yours is
gonna be so much better than mine
whatever who's to say you're even coming
along kid are you [ __ ] kidding me
oh this is [ __ ]
I'm not staying behind Gabe
take a breath he's my dad I'm going it's
going to be dangerous out there
and I don't want anyone else getting
hurt if we get to save dad been getting
hurt is worth it it's worth dying for
this is more important to me than anyone
else I've got a gun and I know how to
use it no way anybody is dying
not today that's why we have to take the
time to talk it through so everybody
comes out okay hey people are the worst
nobody here is gonna let you be a martyr
Gabe your life is precious life is
precious then how come he shot Conrad
huh back in the tunnel when he came
after us he tried to bargain with you
well you thought killing him would be
easier I saved your life too in case you
didn't remember that part so what you
shot him
you killed him he had gone to his head
what the [ __ ]
hobby is she telling the truth you
murdered my friend what the [ __ ] did you
do that for you look me in the eyes man
he had a gun on him if I hadn't killed
him he was gonna shoot Clementine and
Gabe he's telling the truth when Conrad
found out that I used to run with new
frontier he went crazy that coat that
precious little trigger no question I
guess we'll never know right cuz he's
not here to tell his side of things trip
I wasn't sure here bro looks like you're
a pretty [ __ ] dangerous person to be
around avi first you kill my friend then
you get me and my friends a joke
stiffest I think you need to give us
some space hobby [ __ ] that I don't want
to see you ever again
well maybe I'd be better off with Joe
least I know she will stab me in the
back did you stay gone I'm not
accountable you feel me
alright we could take care of ourselves
hell we stick around you much longer
you'll probably kill us too I'm sorry it
happened the way it did really Conrad
wasn't a bad guy the situation was just
just [ __ ] they meant to that we better
go get that truck I'll get my stuff then
call you on the walkie when I see it
feels like trying to get out of here cuz
so awkward my parents fight you know
okay bye
a blueberry ahh num num num num num num
okay buzz come on you come with me to
get the truck get even Kate you guys
hang back here be ready for anything
you're punishing me coz I told everyone
what you did right it's leather I'm
going to get the truck you stay behind
and keep watch you proved your [ __ ]
point already game now it's time to grow
up and help us okay come on I need you
to watch my back on this one
yeah okay I guess somebody needs to be a
lookout hey Clementine a summit smiling
day why can't she be my daughter
Gabe and I will be fine back here
mm-hmm adding in here locked we can't
catch a break
where does it probably rip this old
Chuck apart in seconds
well this wall shot
this thing looks like it moves too slow
for an escape ok
it's cuz all faster guess they'll be
using that for construction once they
clear this area okay I need like a big
boy truck where's the big boy shucks
there it is baby that's my truck there
it is let's go
the big boy truck is here
mm daddy like mommy and the poopy poopy
a bullfight that's it I'd say about
50/50 Wow smartass holy [ __ ] it's max
come on we gotta hurry and finish before
more people wake up what are we gonna do
we can't start the engine
not without attracting a lot of
attention well on things get in turn on
it's a [ __ ] fly out the rest of us
are going to get behind the truck and
push see if we can't get some distance
between us and them
honey let's tear this battery
oh yeah baby oh yeah baby
geo it up yo it up yo kill kill kill
kill kill kill kill kill Jericho you
need in the after all huh Gabe you're
such a lousy shet I'm just saying I know
you didn't want me to come along just
push the damn trunk
alright what you think I'm doing I'm
doing all the work you're the one trying
to have a conversation here okay if you
were such a [ __ ] perhaps more like it
don't think those guys will be able to
hear the engine all the way over here I
put it in neutral couldn't find an
ignition key in there guess you'll have
to Hotwire it
try not to shock yourself
I never hot-wired a car before I'll need
something to strip the wires they left
all their supplies lying around
there'll be some tools out there
somewhere just try hurry okay now I
gotta tuck to Kate I got some unfinished
business today I wonder where I get bay
can you open himself oh he can't I got
open it for him hmm
can he pick the right tool oh no I guess
I have to pick it for him that's [ __ ]
disgusting okay thanks for helping
almost there
keep an eye out I get it started okay
I'll check on the guys in the office
Clem and I will look out for walkers
okay here goes wire cutter shut up with
this yes um [ __ ] nope I don't
Victoria on ignition battery starter
[ __ ]
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing but
I guess it was cut all them okay
gotta connect the battery to the
ignition that says fine don't get
electrocuted don't come on too cute it
oh [ __ ] I don't know what I pressed
let there be light
[ __ ]
Shania Twain never had this problem
[ __ ]
you uh better hurry oh yeah
[Music]
hey let's go now
smack and fire achievement unlocked baby
you like that baby you like that yeah
daddy likey daddy like a the square is a
couple of blocks away this is a good
place to wait do we have enough gas I'm
not about to turn the engine off again
what now we wait for Ava to call us on
the walkie
so nothing for us to do but sit and
watch the Sun come up
perfect time no we've got something
important to do
I'm teaching you to play euchre that's
not a real thing it's a card game come
on it's fun
if seconds - that's nice to be driving
around with a couple kids in the
backseat again really takes you back
doesn't it just you and me and Gabe's
and Mari you're right
this is nice if I just close my eyes
we're right back where we were all of us
together do what I do try to think about
the nice stuff not everything that
happened after
oh yeah like Mariana gay and Shama have
you come on that's not even a good rule
still got you Jess you stop playing it
cool with her hmm ah in case you haven't
noticed it's got a little crush on
Clementine she light like sir you get it
I hope it works out for them I really do
they're good for each other what you
think their first official date will be
target practice
then skimming and eating a wild animal
Oh young love - are you gonna kiss eh or
what
you know like as crazy as things get is
terrible and tragic and just plain
stupid you call these blades they're
butterfly ordinary has two kids falling
for each other not very hair yet love
you would not to feel something that
would intensly for another person kind
of like the best rope there is okay
falling in love is the easy part it's
the staying in love part that'll really
mess you up it's unfair that's all I'm
saying that they're feeling what they're
feeling right now and when that Sun gets
a little higher it's right back to the
fight I just wish he could have had a
childhood you know I wish I could have
given him that him and Mari laugh that's
why we're doing this thing right so he
can have a better life after everything
said and done you're right I know you're
right I hope you know javi having you
there with me
right by my side all this time that's
what made the difference your kiss my
breasts are too sure what you're doing
all this for you didn't run away you
could have but you didn't
I'm here so I can set an example for
people for Gabe especially someone to be
proud of someone who sticks around ah
there's no graceful way to say that I'm
just gonna say it say it say it [ __ ]
I know we've had moments you and I and
there are always a little hot and a
little confusing and maybe some of them
haven't fair way cowboy buckle up before
whatever happened tomorrow happens I
need you to know whatever this thing is
between us I want to give it a chance
and I know the fact that David is back
in our lives now makes this whole thing
a little more complicated but did you
feel the same way I'd really like to
know let's go for it we got a try right
oh my gosh really really so are we gonna
oh yes oh oh yes yes okay yeah [ __ ]
we're doing this we're doing this fab
realize we're gonna have to have a weird
conversation with David right yes
the right way to play this he already
got the sense I was pulling away that
would be the stand-up thing to do in
this situation can I just say how lame
doing the stand-up thing is though oh
it's super lame hobby executional
planning to hang David run of the whole
crowd okay I'll do that God get over
here now
don't bring the truck if they don't kill
him right away did you just get into the
squirrel [ __ ] we got to get over there
now
what you looking at before she was like
hey you know I'm going to hang back here
with the truck keep the walkie close by
we'll tell you as soon as we've got
David oh yeah babe a good luck oh yeah
babe a nothing else for Mabel nope
having sounds like a crowd out there
sounded like Ava got cut off by
something or somebody whoa
wish we had some idea of what we're
heading into like is the whole plan shot
or did she just have a little setback I
hate not knowing I'm getting a little
worried about Eva something must have
gone wrong something must have happened
we're not gonna know what went wrong
until we actually do this thing so let's
do it already you ready you just have to
remember we're going to do something
risky we've got to make sure we
protected ourselves exactly we're gonna
get dad back we can't fight there hmm
okay that's probably it for the episode
all right are they going to end right
there
david garcia has to be punished for what
you stop thanking me for years now
richmond has been governed by one simple
principle strong council strong
community i love strong woman but
unfortunately the actions of one of the
members of that council our security
expert david garcia have put us all
lying to all of you I'm sorry to have to
show you this truly I am but you all
need to see just look what he's done oh
my god his brother and the rest of his
people to kill our doctor and they were
happy to do it who's our guy we walk in
charge someone this reckless this cruel
not if I have anything to do with it
can't believe this is really happening
she's gonna kill him Gabe you were such
a [ __ ] did he do this to him he's kept
him see I knew John was willing to fight
dirty but this is taking you to the next
level you gotta be ready to match your
game I think you're right
I heard you were planning to crash our
little party why did you come on up here
show your face everyone I'm sure these
people would like to hear what you have
to say [ __ ] that and [ __ ] you John I
don't have anything to say to someone
who [ __ ] talks my family don't make this
harder on yourself IV err get up here
now she knows we're here now we might as
well write that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I guess he
out there we both know you killed dr.
lingard why javi
why would you do that to us the only
surgeon in a hundred mile radius but you
didn't care about that dr. lingard had a
problem he couldn't stay out of his own
supply he asked me to put him out of his
misery I was only doing what he wanted
sorry if I don't take your word for it
too bad you killed the only man who
could back up your story I had a very
interesting conversation with your
friend Eleanor last night
isn't that right Eleanor we did she said
you were coming here today to take me
out L knew her total don't know how you
thought you were going to pull it off
considering if all of us against the
three of you and that's exactly what I'm
planning to do appreciate the honesty
which makes this so much harder here in
Richmond people who put themselves
before the group don't last long all
right if it's not gonna make it we're
making a mistake
yeah a base oh no it happened to school
time okay here's the plan
wanted to tear this whole place down he
told his people where to find our gun
supplies and sure enough they picked us
clean you really thought you could ride
into town and staged a coup with our own
damn weapon something like that hmm I
can't just let it go put me in a no-win
situation here so I'm gonna do the same
thing to you both of them deserves to
die for their crime
however hobby I'll let you spare one of
them just one no hell no job go not
after what they tried to do you may be
guilty of bringing them into this but
they chose they instead if you're gonna
punish anyone it should be me not then
so ready to sacrifice yourself for
others
don't worry hobby
I'm not through with you yet mmm Joan
are you sure about this
we never agreed to kill all these people
it's really up to Harvey isn't it all
eyes are on you maybe this will help you
make up your mind boys come on Harvey
who's it gonna be your friends or your
brother's new friend so dad I ain't
gonna pick everything close water now oh
come on stupid you can't be serious
can you Jill the right thing javi how
could you do this this game is like a
China making the bag I thought that I
don't you Wow okay first time died in
this game yeah why not like a hero David
wanted to tear this whole place down he
told his people where to find out guns
okay well sure enough they picked us
Cleve you really thought you could ride
into town and staged a coup with our own
damn weapons something like that I can't
just let it go you put me in a no-win
situation tickers talking you I'm gonna
think a while obviously because she's
been good she's kind of crazy but I want
to punish Eleanor for being a little a
little bit no not after what he tried to
do okay do you take me in Spanish
how do you like to skip ahead so ready
to sacrifice yourself for others
don't worry javi I'm not through with
you yet
it's Java but okay sure about this never
afraid to kill him all these people it's
really up to Harvey isn't it job eh
again but okay Batman I'll help you make
up your mind
boys come on hobby
I got a threaten them but if I don't
choose they kill they your friends say
whatever let evil live he's always been
loyal with no well there's a hobby I
know back don't talking no-good dirty
[ __ ] murderer elder you betrayed me
so L know it's a trade mate
I said don't shooting huh you did but
there's something else you need to
understand betrayal Joan think about
what you're doing it was one of us you
can [ __ ] there you go that's sec okay
oh my god they really shot her god damn
it now gave it it's your turn
Wow
I can't believe this this isn't how we
do think this is madness
stopper click is this a process you
trust it no think about this hot you
know what's gonna happen here you ready
for that
we don't murder in Richmond we exile
that's how we've always done things well
about you too elated and the rest of
your people and just get the hell out
think I far away from Richmond and then
whatever you do is up to you
I'm sure the herd outside was like that
she thinks she's sending us out there to
die she's counting on everybody put your
guns away we're gonna handle this
peacefully okay don't listen to them
hobby they're [ __ ] butchers all of
them shoot that [ __ ] take her out she
deserves it if you don't do it I [ __ ]
will taking a deal all of us right now I
didn't say you could go doesn't matter
if you did this is how it needs to
happen cuz then he's gonna try and kill
Joan and then they're gonna kill him
what what are you I don't believe any of
you take your deal and shoving they're
liars Clint all of them one step closer
and I kill him I swear I will is just
getting interesting aren't you
they can't be trusted with a [ __ ] come
on D don't do this I ain't saying [ __ ]
sorry little brother she's not gonna win
I can't let her I take it I was counting
on this oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] check holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] next about it
[Applause]
exhaling thanks brah oh they're shots
there
there's John rivers thank you to stop
him I need you to cover me
we got to make things right okay Gabe
don't go dad needs us we gotta get out
there
[ __ ] that [ __ ] David's trained for this
we're not you think you'll be okay out
there
yeah kudos chick a knocker with chip
there
I'm kind of sad that she needs us I got
a helper to go I honestly have never
understood why trip continually tries to
be my friend I honestly have no idea do
something to [ __ ] this up I told you
what he was like what are you gonna
start believing me right there man
fire what the hell is going on over
there are you guys okay stay away from
quick it's too risky
we'll come to you hey I can't hear you
it's too loud oh great I'm so tired of
grenade wow this is tear gas
I am vagina Liang Liang like dong Fang
[Music]
oh great Kate she's coming for us
shut
songs and oil you've got to get over
there before Hey
well ice I got the kisser no J
[Music]
[Applause]
okay next of a live I mean I'll take an
armored truck she may still be alive I
know I think it's light episode right
let's say okay the right at the price of
dress does my guy I can hang Joan Rivers
and you promised help Kate with your
family if David left yes okay how do you
respond we assist the suicide did he
tell her yes everybody did
did you try and save Ava most people did
did you shoot your own or take Glenn
steel to do okay good job good job
lot of ways thanks for watching and
we'll see you miss level up so Charlotte
thank you